as you can tell by my apron I'm a
[ __ ] sauce boss Thank You Harley from
Epic Meal Time he didn't send this to me
I bought it myself because I don't think
he likes me
[Laughter]
[Music]
today my friends we're gonna be cooking
a very special Hawaiian treat known as
loco moco that's loco isn't crazy that's
moco as in motors now the local mobile
that I'm making is gonna be different
we're gonna have to mommy bombs going
off left and [ __ ] right first things
first let's get that gravy going I'm
gonna move this pan out the lake because
it's pissing me off
what we're going to do first off let's
get a little bit of oil put it in the
pot you're going to sweat out these
mushrooms and the reason why you want to
sweat it out first is because we want to
get the moisture out of this [ __ ] so
we'll start off on a relatively warm pan
it doesn't need to be blazing hot
because that's not what we're doing with
this now the best way for you to extract
liquid out of things is to add a little
salt and do it salt-based style for out
let it drizzle across that oh it's not
getting in the pot we're going to layer
those flavors together and we're going
to sweat this out for roughly about a 7
to 10 minutes we took the moisture out
it's gone it's done the mushrooms are
brown they are very tender the next
thing that we're going to do we are
going to add the fat component no we're
not online we're going to throw the
onions in that they're less sweat out
these onions just like we did with the
mushrooms we want them to be a delicious
delicious what do we call it what do we
call that a Chris Brown Brown now we've
gotten the onions and the mushrooms to
this point it has fried in that oil
the mushrooms are brown and the onions
are a nice golden brown as well you
could smell it it's gonna smell like
delicious onion rings dump that
[ __ ] out we're gonna throw the bacon in
there some of you are like well why
don't you just throw the bacon with that
[ __ ] in there because we need the fat
not to absorb into this cuz we're gonna
make a rule out of the bacon fat what is
a rule you asked my friends a roux is a
mixture of flour and fat a lot of
southern cooking use this as a
thickening agent for a lot of things now
at this point your bacon has danced and
sizzling in the fat and all the fat is
rendered out next up we're gonna create
that room now depending on how much
flour you use is really going to depend
on how much gravy you want out of your
stuff so with me I got roughly about 2/3
cup of flour and if you rooms a little
too thick and it's a little clumpy just
add a little more oil to it and the
reason why I'm stirring it you probably
don't have to stir it as vigorously as I
am but I don't want this to have any
burn spots because if your Roux burns
your [ __ ] you have to start all over
again you have to render the bacon fat
again next up is your liquid we're gonna
add this a little bit at a time it gets
in there you see what that Roux does you
get this weird paste you're like what is
this this isn't gravy you know why cuz
you didn't add enough liquid we're gonna
do this in increments so basically at
this point when your gravy gets to a
rough boiling point that's how thick
it's going to be now that we got the
gravy done and ready next up my friends
is going to be the beef patty local moco
this is a hundred percent pure grass-fed
no it's not if you are gonna cook your
ground beef patty to about a medium or
so make sure that you use fresh ground
beef this is fresh so we're good you
hear that you hear that hear that hear
that hear that yeah you do
but we're gonna let this cook and get it
happy get Mary brown crust afire etc etc
let the fat creep over here on this side
let it come to this side let it get it
outside let it go to west side two
minutes have passed
take your patty let the oil dance where
you're going to put it flip it and look
at that color on that patty this is what
you want the my yard reaction you only
get that from a heat and fat we are
gonna let this go for another minute and
a half two minutes or so and it's going
to be perfect ready and sexy so it
doesn't overcook we're gonna take the
patty away put it on this disposable
plate and let it rest for a bit and by
the time that's rested it's gonna cook
all the way through next up my friends
just to make sure that it's all gonna
happen we are gonna cook an egg a local
moco is not a local moco without a
little eggs a fried delicious golden egg
take that egg put it on that surf bet I
heard white people don't salt their
fried eggs
is that true why people I do you're
gonna take your rice put it into a bowl
make sure it's smashed all the way
around okay take your rice take your
plate like such flip it to make a
beautiful mound next up take that
beautiful beef patty put it on top
get a spoon mix it up again make sure
that I hit my toe one of those moments
take your delicious umami five gravy
with all those Bacon's the mushrooms the
onions oh and you are going to place it
right on top like this and don't be
stingy with it too
I don't know why people always send you
with sauce and gravy you want people to
love you after that we are gonna take
our beautiful fried
sunny-side up egg place it on top
don't forget the bonito flakes that we
had earlier
we're just attacking every single animal
on earth we're doing beef we're doing
pork we're doing fish bonito flakes my
friends is a dried cured fish that a lot
of Japanese people use we're gonna throw
those bonito flakes on top don't be too
messy with it add a little nori to make
it pretty and there you have it my
friends we have my famous David so I
call it by miso loco moco and this my
friends is the miso loco moco umami bomb
in your mouth thank you later ooh this
is gonna be my favorite part of cooking
food it's the eating part now we have
saucy bossiness everywhere we have the
gravy and of course watch this [ __ ]
break the egg yolk and we have a sex
volcano ooh little bit of bonito flake
everything else burgers cooked to a
medium
and that's how you make a [ __ ] local
moco it's comfort food man no fancy
it doesn't look like I'm [ __ ]
cucumber sandwich well this is the stuff
that you'll serve your kids your friends
and maybe your girlfriend she's a
linebacker in the NFL get yourself a
nice little little little little little
little uh what do you call this thing
black pot ha ha ha and you want to make
sure you got to get doing what you're
doing your kids are starving
your girlfriend's waiting for you you
got that weird hentai porn that you
masturbate to you sick [ __ ] freaks
tentacle porn to watch that stuff
anymore I don't to be honest with you
but you throw onions into a pot or pan
it basically smells like you know what
you're doing isn't that right Lin yeah
that's right shut the [ __ ] up are you
are like who that's not a Southie what
do you have to add so much how about you
shut the [ __ ] up you don't know what
makes your food taste delicious you just
sit in the restaurant and all you do is
Yelp and criticize but you don't know
how much fat and butter goes into your
stuff so how about you shut the [ __ ] up
and learn what I'm cooking so you can
impress your friends and tell them to
shut the [ __ ] up you make me because I
know that you when you sneeze sneeze
away from your food unless you really
love your guests